hey guys looks like the seven deadly
sins manga is wrapping up so make sure
to follow us on our twitch link in the
description where we'll be discussing
the newest chapter tomorrow at 5 p.m.
Eastern Time we discussed the chapters
weekly on Wednesdays at this time so
we'll be discussing all of the final
chapters together week by week join us
and let us give a proper send-off to
these amazing characters that we've
grown to love so much alright now let's
get into some overpowered greatness cue
that intro
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and in this video I'm going to be
counting down some of the most Opie
abilities in the seven deadly sins I
love the fact that there are so many
special abilities in this series and so
I wanted to explore some of the most
Opie ones in more detail make sure to
LIKE and subscribe for more seven deadly
sins videos if you desperately need even
more seven deadly sins content you can
follow us on instagram at anime out
drawer where you'll find daily seven
deadly sins posts keep in mind this is
not simply a list of the most Opie
characters you can watch the top ten
overpowered characters video if you are
looking for that this is specifically
about abilities so you will add time see
weaker characters ranking higher than
stronger characters because of the
quality of their specific ability at the
end of the day this is just for fun and
it's my opinion if you think differently
that's totally cool let me know how you
drank them differently or if you'd
include an Opie ability that I left out
manga spoilers lie ahead now without
further ado let's jump into some ope
abilities at number 10 I got crisis the
original demons original power as the
original demon describes it the more
life that has shaved away the more his
power grows in proportion thus all
damage that he takes that doesn't kill
him only makes him stronger if miles
move great a son didn't finish him off
we can hardly imagine how much the
damage would have increased his power
the issue of course is that the original
demon's body because of the curse placed
on him by the demon king is constantly
breaking down and it is only a matter of
time before he would eventually destroy
himself it is a problem too that you
have to take damage to increase your own
power since getting stronger ironically
means you are taking on more damage and
as a result possibly getting closer to
your own defeat for these reasons I
won't place the ability any higher but
it was definitely an impressive and
interesting ability to give to an
already overpowered character at number
9 we have full counter an ability Mele
Otis learned from Chandler Mele Otis's
version of full counter reflex attack
magic back at the enemy with even
greater power so the stronger the
opponent the more formidable the move
becomes the drawback is you can't
initiate an attack
full counter but if you are already a
good fighter it is an excellent ability
to add to your repertoire ester osa also
possess full counter but instead of
magic attacks he could reflect only
physical attacks as a serosa tells us
kannur any physical attack made against
him he can return many times over since
these are supposedly abilities that one
is able to learn that it would be very
interesting if one could learn both and
be able to reflect all magic and
physical attacks too that would make one
practically invincible as long as they
could keep up with the speed of their
opponent's attacks the great thing about
full counter is it doesn't actually
require a lot of power to use so even if
you're way weaker like one of
melioidosis clones you can still reflect
a much stronger opponents attack right
back at them and defeat them in that way
lastly there is revenge counter a
version of full counter where malleolus
purposely takes damage in order to
eventually reflect all the accumulated
damage back at once because he's
absorbed multiple attacks and not just
one his final attack will be much more
powerful at number eight is bond snatch
ability it allows him to steal things
like items weapons or even an opponent's
heart or heart if we're talking about
demons who have seven hearts as is
explained in chapter 35 bonds magic
power snatch doesn't only steal objects
it can also temporarily rob someone of
their physical abilities against
meliodas
bond robs the captain of his speed and
adds it to his own this move is called
physical hunt and it allows him to fill
his own body with additional physical
power stolen from his opponent it can
increase his own strength and speed
drastically while decreasing that of the
opponent hunter fest is the upgraded
version of this ability that he uses
against GLE and he can rob the physical
strength of every person within a
several hundred foot radius of him this
is enough to temporarily let him
overpower Galan but the drawback is that
his body's tolerance level limits how
much power he can steal and there's a
limit to how long he can keep it up this
is why he cannot steal all gallons power
and finish him off
this is also why he can't keep fighting
for a long time and eventually as a
result of absorbing so much power he
undergoes a recovery period during which
can't lift even a single finger however
bonds body's tolerance level
dramatically increases in purgatory so
he can potentially steal much more
physical power for an extended period of
time
furthermore snatch lets him used a move
zero sign which steals other people's
perception of him allowing him to sneak
up on enemies he can now also give power
to others with the move gift so all in
all this ability is extremely versatile
and opie but it is not without its
drawbacks especially if it belongs to a
person with a low body tolerance level
so for that reason it did in place even
higher on this list at number 7 we have
ominous nebula as we're told in Chapter
288 the true nature of ominous nebula is
that by increasing his concentration to
the limit zelgius revolves his own
darkness at top speed creating an
intense whirlpool that pulls in all
nearby creatures to him and then
anything that enters its range is cut
down to bits by a slashing attack so
Swift it's impossible to avoid by any
spinal reflex one could call it full
react as Ludo shell an archangel known
for being one of the fastest beings ever
says calling the attack Swift doesn't do
it justice looter shell admits that the
attack surpasses him and suggests that
it is entering a divine realm because of
how opie it is zelgius uses this
original power in combination with the
power he's borrowed from the demon king
which makes him resistant to all magic
attacks while ominous nebulae should in
theory make him impervious to physical
attacks it is one of the most opie
combinations in the show but is
ultimately thwarted by esken or into one
mode there is no doubt it is an Opie
ability but it would not be as good
without the demon Kings resistance to
magic attacks ultimately Eskin ores
ability sunshine proves to be even more
overpowered and puts a stop to it more
on that later but for now let's move on
to number six which is Merlin's ability
infinity this ability is so good that
she got both the demon king and supreme
deity to give her extremely valuable
gifts in the hope that she would join
their side of course she doesn't but
still manages to escape unharmed from
these two godlike figures her ability
allows her to stop her own time
in her true form she looks like she
hasn't aged a bit since the holy war
even though 3,000 years have passed
since then this will allow her to live
forever in theory which is very valuable
to her as a mage because the whole time
she is gaining knowledge and learning
about or coming up with new spells and
combinations
Merlin's ability infinity is so opie
that she is often accused of cheating
and foul play all she needs to do is to
invoke a spell once and she can use her
power to keep it going forever until she
decides to cancel it out we see just how
crazy infinity can be when she used the
in combination with other spells to
overpower cusack and Chandler two of the
strongest demons in history before they
transformed into the original demon she
sets it up so that the attacks keep
coming at the two for as long as they
keep moving even Ludo shell who is on
the same side thinks that Merlin's power
has to be against the rules at this
point the possibilities are literally
infinite at number five we got the
ability to transform into an enduro it's
a transformation that demons was a
combat class of over 50,000 can undergo
by sacrificing six of their seven hearts
we see both derrière E and mon speed
undergo this transformation in chapter
206 they go from losing against three
Archangels to absolutely wrecking that
as molasse killa points out the Summoner
exchanges his original form and sense of
reason in order to take on the ultimate
evil form in Durres are called creatures
of destruction I can't help but wonder
how strong malleolus would be if he the
source of destruction also became an
enduro the creature of destruction that
would just be insane but even for much
weaker demons it drastically raises
their power Ludo Shaw who was clearly
overpowering on speed and derriere II
before their transformations finds that
his attacks now have no effect
and he goes from winning to being a
punching bag liked our meal and Sarnia
Ludo shell in Margaret's body reaches a
power level of 200 1000 and we have
every reason to believe that it was even
higher in his original goddess body and
yet he was no match for the Enduro
transformations which were not even
complete yet it definitely comes with a
heavy price to pay
but disability is definitely a no P one
in the prisoner of the sky movie
stopping one in Deraa took the combined
efforts of the sins the mother of chaos
aka Hawks mom and the Celestials I would
love to see how strong malleolus would
become if he underwent this
transformation as long as Elizabeth is
around to turn him back to normal
afterwards as she did with derriere II
and won't speed number four is sunshine
the ability that made Eskin or one of
the most Opie characters ever and that
made mile even stronger than that
as we know the ability sunshine ensures
that the wielder gets stronger as the
Sun approaches its highest point in the
sky in the beginning it doesn't even
take High Noon for s kannur to easily
overpower all of his opponents including
the land molasse Kayla and Esther osa
the guy who was responsible for
temporarily killing our main character
all of these Commandments were more than
a match for the other sins in the
beginning but with sunshine s Kannur who
has a base power level at midnight of 15
was able to crush them this speaks to
how Opie sunshine is it can turn a
character who has half the combat class
of hawk into the most Opie member of the
seven deadly sins at least for a time
sunshine also allows us Kannur to become
the one during high noon as Merlin
explains for one minute ESCA noir
becomes the invincible incarnation of
power in this mode ESCA nor can take out
assault mode malleolus with a swipe of
his hand keep in mind this was malleolus
at the power level that he possessed
when he commanded a ten commandments and
the one still can effortlessly take him
out furthermore he can stop zelgius opie
ability on this nebula with a karate
chop in the one form the ability
sunshine proves to be even stronger in
miles possession afternoon mile can stop
ominous nebulae with his proximity alone
in that proximity even melt zelgius a
sword something that s can ORS the one
form didn't do afternoon mile was able
to take out the original demon with one
attack but what's really exciting is how
strong he could potentially get in the
one form during High Noon
not only has sunshine proved to be
extremely overpowered it is also clear
that we haven't even
it used to its full potential so far at
number three we have the demon Kings
original power the ruler as stated in
chapter 284 the ruler ability changes
any attack in weakening maneuvers made
against you into healing and
rejuvenating ones instead in other words
a reversal this ability is actually
insanely opie but bond happens to learn
how to give power which turns out to be
disabilities Achilles heel since giving
power is reversed also and it becomes
taking away power instead yet it's not
even really much of a weakness since the
demon king can just deactivate the power
so bond can no longer hurt him in that
way
keep in mind Maya Lin the one mode could
launch the greatest son known to man
attack at the demon king and it would
not only do zero damage it would
actually heal and fortify him instead
I think the demon Kings ability was
overcome quickly for the reader despite
the fact that in the world of the series
it helped a demon king ensure victory
against bonhomie Leodis and astounding
6090 three times in the span of 60
purgatory years it was overcome because
bond happened to have a specific ability
snatch that eventually evolved in a
specific way so that the demon king was
forced to deactivate the ruler however
if it wasn't for that lucky break Mele
ODIs and bond might have never escaped
purgatory at all thus we should keep in
mind that there wouldn't always be an
ability as convenient as bonds ability
which forces the user of the ruler to
deactivate his opie ability in most
cases he would be able to go on using it
to his advantage in second place we had
Kings ability disaster which has grown
with him into one of the most Opie
abilities ever disaster and how it
allows King to expertly control the
spear spear is what gave me the idea to
actually do this video in the first
place
I missed it the first time but on
rereading chapter of 281 I noticed that
king with full-grown wings is using at
least four spirit spears at the same
time not only is each form much stronger
than it was before individually but
before he could only use one spear spear
at a time and now he can use four or
even more which is just insane to think
about but I'm getting ahead of myself
the ability design
so versatile and can do so many things
that we should probably start with the
basics as Merlin explains Kings original
magic power disaster allows him to turn
the littlest cut into a mortal wound
change poison into a deadly poison and
increased the size of a tiny tumor his
technique condensed power allows him to
condense a water droplet and turn it
into a deadly bullet that's as hard as
steel all of this is impressive on its
own but the ability really shines when
it's combined with Kings sacred treasure
as gila explains in chapter 25 it is his
original magic power disaster that
actually allows him to summon forth the
legendary spirit Spears power as of now
we've currently seen eight forms that
chasse aful can take and we know that
King can use at least four at the same
time and probably more disability
allowed him to easily beat a mile with
four commandments whose power level was
over 200,000 when the combined efforts
of the N go through and a pre full wings
King could do absolutely nothing the
ability also allows him to fight from a
ridiculously long distance the drawback
is that I waste a lot of magic quickly
and he can use only one spear spear at a
time from a distance but he was still
able to almost take out the original
demon and overpower zelgius even with
these disadvantages I believe that the
fourth form sunflower would have taken
the original demon out just like miles
greatest son and that is wise I'll just
stepped in to help and canceled out the
magic attack using the magic resistance
he borrowed from the demon king I can't
go into every form his sacred treasure
can take and we still haven't seen all
of the enhanced versions of the
different forms or King go all out with
the ability and a full tank of magic but
even still no ability except perhaps the
one in first place that we'll get to
soon has impressed me as much as Kings
disaster ability its strength and
versatility easily make it one of the
most Opie abilities in the series and in
first place the most opie ability is
Mele Otis's original power for a long
time malleolus was afraid to awaken his
original power that's how strong it is
the demon king a God in the world of the
seven deadly sins was powerless be
formerly Otis's original power Mellie
Otis's emotions alone could use the
original power to destroy the demon
King's entire arm keep in mind that most
of the strongest creatures alive would
have trouble penetrating the top layer
of his flesh and Mellie Otis tore
through his armor skin and even bone
with his power this godlike figure
panicked and screamed after Mellie Otis
when he saw how strong he was the demon
king said Mellie Otis was special
because he was a source of destruction
or the destroyer so some of you think
that Mellie Otis is original power is
called a destroyer similarly to how the
demon King's is called the ruler that
would make sense since his original
power definitely seems to be tied with
destruction it's as if it allows Mellie
Otis to destroy anything the demon king
has also referred to the power as Mellie
Otis's inner demon lord power
apparently it's so strong that he can't
last a day in this mortal plane with it
no other ability on this list has been
so key that the user couldn't even stay
in the human world once it was awakened
Mellie Otis uses this godly power with
Kings technique condense power to
absolutely destroy the demon king
Mellie Otis's ability makes the demon
king who was previously presented as an
almighty godlike figure look absolutely
helpless that is pretty much as Opie as
you can get and that is it for today's
video thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed the video make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
have and make sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you are
notified when brand new seven deadly
sins videos drop for daily seventh at
least sends posts and conversations
definitely check out our Instagram at
Anime uproar a big thank you goes out to
our patrons especially our protea
patrons keelon and the one and only
Gilgamesh and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans maddie
mac two three nine and a seventeen FF DP
your support is greatly appreciated if
you want to support us you can do so for
as little as one dollar a month and your
name will even appear alongside these
amazing people in future videos just
check out the link in the description
and lastly if you're interested in
rocking some seven deadly sins inspired
merge like Eskin or praise the Sun and
Mel yonas feel the wrath be sure to
check out anime uproar calm thanks again
and until next time see us BAE
Cowboys
[Music]